people from black and ethnic minority
communities are being disproportionately
affected by the corona virus pandemic in
the last hour the Office for National
Statistics has released figures looking
into deaths from kovat 19 broken down by
factors including ethnicity black men
are 4.2 times more likely to die of
covin 19 and black women are 4.3 times
more likely to lose their life to covin
19 than their white counterparts
while skies enzmann Rashid is in the
newsroom as of when people have long
looked at the apparent disparity amongst
this but these are the hard facts they
are these stats coming out from the
Office for National Statistics this
morning at and we've been talking about
this for about three to four weeks now
ever since we got an idea that Kobe 19
was disproportionately affecting the
black Asian and minority ethnic
community and now these stats really
confirming that we've had a lot of
anecdotal reports and and very early
reports from different organizations but
these hard stats which include figures
from the ons and NHS England and Wales
really are confirming that issue that B
AME people are disproportionately
affected as a result of kovat 19 and and
the death rates are showing that now
these stats from ons clearly say that
the biggest risk appears to be in black
men and women when accounting for age
which is what they've done in this
analysis black men are 4.2 times more
likely to die with kovat 19 and black
women are 4.3 times more likely to die
than their white counterparts and the
risk then is reduced slightly but only
two to 1.9 times once their factors are
taken in and those factors include
socioeconomic factors and also health
conditions now the interesting thing
about this report from the ons is that
it's actually the first time Adam that
we've seen figures not only from
hospitals across England but also in the
community across England and
Wales as well it's the first time we're
actually witnessing the ethnicity deaths
amongst those communities in those two
nations and what it also suggests is
that there are some important factors
that are playing a role amongst the
disproportionate number of deaths and
those include socio-economic issues and
deprivation amongst the B AME community
and also underlying health conditions
now those could include things like type
2 diabetes it could include heart
problems as well which is obviously a
huge problem when it comes down to
dealing with coronavirus when you are in
intensive care and in those critical
units and also the social deprivation
comes down to a number of factors
including overcrowded housing and
cultural factors like multi-generational
housing where it really makes it quite
difficult to self isolate into social
distance in those areas meaning that
viral load is quite high now there is a
bit of discrepancy within these ons
figures and and there's a segment really
where they haven't accounted for a
specific factor and that potentially
could be a result of occupation Adam we
know that people from a black Asian
minority ethnic community are working in
these key worker roles throughout this
pandemic a lot of them on the frontline
in the NHS fighting kovat 19 a lot of
them driving buses they're more
vulnerable to getting the virus tube
drivers here in London as well and those
working in shops as well and that
potentially also has a huge role to play
in the disproportionate number of deaths
I just want to give you some more
insight into this report from the Office
of National Statistics as well they say
that males in the Bangladeshi and
Pakistani ethnic group were at one point
eight times more likely to have Co vyd
19 related deaths and women from those
backgrounds a 1.6 times more likely to
have kovat 19 related deaths to their
white counterparts and they also say
that Chinese and myth mixed ethnic
groups are also among
that group as well so clearly the ONS
stats today confirming what we've been
speaking about for the last three weeks
that they there is clearly a
disproportionate difference here in the
number of pame deaths in comparison to
the general population and what the
questions will be now to the government
is what are they going to do to try and
prevent further deaths like this
happening throughout this pandemic and
if another one happens in the future